hey sorry I'm getting this Lincoln
review up light hopefully if history
remembers me which it probably most
definitely will not but if it does it
won't remember me as the douchebag who
got his Lincoln review up late and did
Twilight before it said yeah Lincoln so
Lincoln's directed by Steven Spielberg
and it's about pretty much the legacy of
Abraham Lincoln passing the Thirteenth
Amendment which is the amendment to
abolish slavery when I was going into
this movie I was like all right I'm
gonna watch a three-hour movie about
Lincoln's life these biographical
pictures are like that sometimes you
know it shows the entire person's life
75% of it doesn't really matter and that
25% is what you came for you know it's
like the thick of it this movie just
does away with all of that all right
let's concentrate on the last few months
of his life and him trying to pass this
13th amendment and I love this movie for
that I loved it for that many other
things so Abraham Lincoln is portrayed
by Daniel day-lewis kind of and by that
I mean Abraham Lincoln is in this movie
and that is simply that you know the
legend of Abraham Lincoln the holy he's
all four score and seven years ago this
movie portrays he wasn't like that he
kind of had hunched posture and always
took like this you know he always had
his story to tell about someone someone
you knew someone you heard of any way I
love that it just peels back the legend
of Abraham Lincoln and it gives us
Abraham Lincoln the man a human being
the person who's just trying to do
something because he just feels it's the
best thing to do people have the right
to dignity now this movie has an
enormous cast a cast of people who are
you like oh that person's in this movie
oh wow that person's didn't move that
person didn't this movie - Jared Harris
is in it you know I love that dude
Joseph gordon-levitt's in the movie
Jackie Earle Haley this movie has such
an enormous cast I'm not even gonna
remotely mention everyone James Spader's
in this movie I don't think James Spader
ever knows he's being filmed in the
office and in Lincoln they're just like
James Spader's doing something go go go
go just film him Tommy Lee Jones in this
movie Tommy Lee Jones is just intense
he's like Abraham Lincoln's opposite you
know he will just get in someone's face
and call him a snake and a piece of
Abraham Lincoln never really lost his
cool there were a couple scenes where he
was like you know what now it's a time
to get a little intense and angry but
for the most part he was just a really
poised purse and he just he never melted
down on anyone now although this - the
wars going on in this move
you don't really see a lot of the civil
war you see another kind of war a war in
a room of politicians and that's what
this movie is it's the war of words
it's the chess play that you have to do
to pass something like this cuz this was
unprecedented people are like well
abolish slavery let's not get carried
away please
the link is like no everyone has the
right to dignity we're going to pass
this and again we don't get the legend
of it we get the reality of this
situation the fact that secrets are kept
no you don't pass something like this
and keep your hands completely clean I
personally love that a movie like this
can either bore the hell out of me or I
will be so into it I will love every
minute of it I loved every single minute
of the movie Lincoln when they're doing
the vote you're just so intense you felt
it's built up to this so much you're
just in tears you can just feel the
intensity in your eyes and tears were
there it's funny because you know the
outcome but when you're watching a movie
you lose that a good movie will do that
to you make you lose bits of history as
you're watching it it's like the movie
Lincoln is in the same tradition of the
HBO miniseries John Adams
I watched John Adams I loved it I was
just like I just wanted John Adams to
live and unnaturally and almost
magically long life so I wanted to see
Abraham Lincoln it's like the universe
heard that and they were like hey Jeremy
here's an Abraham Lincoln movie alright
now we got this I'm really surprised if
there's been no real movie about Lincoln
that stands out in my head there's not
that oh this is the definitive Abraham
Lincoln movie I understand why cuz it's
so big I'm sure filmmakers are like love
to do it not going to use if I screw
that up
I will die will die life itself will
blink me out of existence Steven
Spielberg's like I'll do it I did one
about a war horse so Lincoln is
well-directed saying it's well acted is
an understatement it's perfectly acted
Daniel day-lewis will get an Oscar
nomination for this movie and probably
win it focuses on the point of Abraham
Lincoln's life and legacy which is the
passing of the 13th amendment it keeps
you interested it keeps you engaged it
informs you and entertains you that's
all I want from a biographical picture
Lincoln absolutely is awesome tacular
I know I've given out like three of
those in three weeks it's absurd I
recognize I should not give out a lot of
awesome tak users like that can it
dilute the currency at that point but I
also recognize I fully believe all the
movies that I've given awesome tacular
to our awesome tacular I'm not gonna
skip out on giving Lincoln one because
like well you're getting a little
carried away screw that noise and on the
side note if you haven't seen the HBO
miniseries John Adams I suggest watching
John Adams especially if you've seen
Lincoln and you like Lincoln I think
you'll probably like John Adams so your
favorite movie about a president what
would it be comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]